I love writing code.
But if you're
anything like me, then
creating even the most
sophisticated logic
for your apps seems easier
than crafting a great user
interface.
Designs evolve over
time, and testing
every single change in
your layouts on devices
can be tedious.
Enter the Layout Editor, a
tool built into Android Studio
that lets you edit and preview
your layouts in real time,
without the need to
recompile and deploy
the APK on to an actual
device or emulator.
The Layout Editor
automatically kicks in whenever
you open an XML layout file.
The Design view lets you easily
add and manipulate components
by dragging them from the
palette onto the stage.
Visual cues help you position
views relative to each other,
taking into account
the parent node's class
and required layout parameters.
You can edit other view
properties in the Inspector
or change the views place in the
hierarchy in the Component Tree
pane.
There's a handy trick you can
use when you've set up a view
but then decide that you
want to change its class.
Just right-click a view and
select the desired component
from the Morphing menu.
Be aware that there are certain
restrictions in place to only
allow changes that make sense.
So you won't be able to morph a
linear layout into a text view,
for example.
Whenever you see that parts
of your view hierarchy
can be reused in
other layouts, there's
also a refactoring
called Extract Layout.
When you enable it, the
subtree you selected
will be moved into
a separate resource
and included in
your current layout.
When you open the
new file for editing,
you can see it's
still shown embedded
in the original
hierarchy for previewing.
That's because Android
Studio added a special hint
to your XML when it
performed the refactoring.
To see it, let's switch
to editing raw XML
by pressing on the Text tab.
Notice how instead
of the visual editor,
there is now a
live preview window
that updates in real time
as you work on the code.
If you always prefer to see code
instead of the default design
view, just enable the Prefer
XML Editor option here.
The hint for the renderer
that I mentioned before
actually consists of two parts.
First, we have the new tools
namespace on the root XML node.
The other is a set of
special annotations
that don't affect
the runtime but are
processed by Android Studio.
Here, you can see
the Show In property
that renders the
file you're working
on in a context of another
layout in place of the Include
tag.
It's certainly useful, but
there's another type of hint
that really boosted
my productivity
that I wish someone had
pointed out to me sooner.
You can actually override
most of the view properties
just by prefixing them
with the tools namespace.
Seems simple, but look at
how it could work for you.
Ever had a layout with blank
text views because it needs
an adapter to supply data, like
in a list view, for example?
Add dummy text using
the tools namespace,
and make your layout
immediately readable.
What if parts of your layout
are set to Gone or Invisible
and only shown depending
on runtime conditions?
Just override it with tools
visibility for design time.
As you can see, the Layout
Editor is a fantastic tool,
and it's available
in Android Studio.
If you want to learn more or
if you have any other layout
editing tips, share them on
Google+ in the Android Studio
community.
Be sure to check out the other
videos in the Android Studio
DevBytes series.